the female gamer of color you know how
do you feel about the state of black
representation in the games industry as
general and then the second part as far
as like
video game protagonists of color you
know do you think we're starting to see
improvements there do you think more can
be done so how do you feel on both
subjects there
oh sure so i mean starting off huge
shout out to nadine from art uncharted
4.
i loved that character she was so cool
and she had the natural hair which is a
beef i have i'll talk about it it
doesn't seem very important but when you
see black characters in games and they
always have straight hair and i know
that hair and games is still terrible
i'll fully say that hair in games still
looks really bad
and i don't blame people for not wanting
to tackle curly hair but when you see
someone do it right and they take the
care to give this woman a natural look
i just loved her as a character for who
she was she was funny she was tough as
nails she was just cool to be around uh
and she was a villain which is great
then of course in
legacy you get to hang out with chloe
and it's two of them you know tag team
in the world so i adored that and that
experience
it showed me how much it does matter to
me that's something we talked about in
my discussion with colin because he was
sort of saying you know why does it
matter to have representation in games
and one of the examples i gave was that
i'm bi-racial my dad's white my mom's
black as a kid you never saw biracial
families on tv you saw black families
you saw white families and i never
thought anything of it until i saw it
was like an old navy commercial that
showed a biracial family
and it was the first time in my life i
saw someone on tv that looked like i did
and it did matter and that's when i
realized that it does it does feel
different to have people in media that
look like you yes and so i do think
games are going in a great direction i'm
certainly not you know someone that's
like heavily pushing for it because i
want it to be meaningful i don't want
this to feel forced
if you create a great game that has a
black woman in the lead you know right
in the forefront like uncharted 4 they
did an excellent job with that so yeah
absolutely so i'm happy with where our
games are going um
the new call of duty that had like the
black protagonist in that he was an
excellent character he's a strong leader
he was just really fun to you know play
as and the rest of the crew as well so
i'm happy with what we have so far and
just excited to see the future you know
what else they bring us in games
absolutely totally agree and that's why
i wanted to bring that subject up
because i had i had to get you today
dean uh was it jeff or always
mispronounce it just forgive
if gift
sacrilege sorry secretly
okay
because i do i don't watch that
character it definitely meant and um
yeah it's good so i was gonna add
something else after you finish it
it's weird like exactly what micah says
like you don't realize that you want
that representation until you actively
think about it not being there because
oftentimes you just again you just you
watch stuff and you don't think about it
when you're younger necessarily if it
doesn't come up as a subject and as you
get older you start seeing it and you
realize how important it is i remember
just a just a couple of weeks ago my
wife and i sat down and watched
encounter the uh
disney movie
and and then there was a whole you know
sort of meme and gift that came out of
that where a young boy was standing next
to the a character that was in the movie
on the tv and it was he was he was a
biracial kid a dark-skinned had a big
hair afro and the kid you know he saw
himself in that character in a way that
honestly i haven't really seen before
maybe uh looking at like miles morales
in the spider-man movie or something
like that but before that
i'd never really seen that
representation for it to come from
disney you know kind of like
the most evil of evil
it's excellent to see because you know
that on that level it's something that's
being overtly addressed right you have
to and i wish it didn't have to be that
way that you have to do that but again
in order to move forward it has to be
something that that you that you make an
effort to put in these in in games and
in movies and do properly you know so
i want to defend disney right now
[Laughter]
okay
first uh
you know why because my daughters watch
disney stuff and i'm i sit there and i
watch it with them so i see a lot of our
representation in it and they had a lot
of hispanic uh other movies as well and
i just finished watching uh uh luca and
you know about uh two italian uh merman
with my boys which was really good and
and and i and i thought about it while
i'm watching it with my granddaughter
um
i've never saw
and i could be wrong
a movie about italians
uh in like their homeland right right
just sort of americanized stereotypes of
italians right right so i said wow i
said this i said for some italian kid
right now
they're seeing their self
in this right here and i said this must
be so cool right now yeah and it was
just a really good i really liked the
film it made me cry yeah yeah i do cry
i cry all the time
yeah another thing i i do have to give
you the props though because another
thing that i saw um i don't know if you
saw this as well king interstitially
between between movies they'll give like
a little advertisement thing and they
showed a thing where it was a sort of uh
a reel
of all the old you know crazy racist
movies oh yeah and they said they said
this is our past
we know what we've done
yeah we know what we have to change in
the future like they they addressed it
in a way i never thought it would you
know again and as a young kid you watch
all these movies you love these movies
you don't see those things right until
yeah they took them off completely but
the thing about it for them to
acknowledge it that way and actually
just actually just re-show them because
a lot of times you that stuff will
disappear you'll never see it again but
for them to address it so directly and
say hey we're making a concerted effort
to right this wrong was was something
that i saw i was like wow things really
are changing there really is this [ __ ]
our consumer dollars yeah and you're
going to represent us in this uh poor
fashion then we shall not patron your
weirds it's just very simple
um and
if you do want our dollars then you're
going to have to have to represent us
accordingly yeah and like you said you
you saw a commercial and you never
thought about it before until you saw
the commercial with a family that
represented yours and
wow i didn't know i needed something yes
that i didn't see and that's where the
emotional part of it hits right because
sometimes myself like why am i getting
emotional this is a simple thing why
because you don't see it so when you
finally see it you're like okay yeah
because it's me like i'm out here
i remember yeah
i remember what playing miles morales
when i saw pastels
i lost it i lost it my wife walked in
front of the tv she was like i don't
sponsors i'm like yup
different
i watched the whole black panther
my kids are sitting there
and i'm crying throughout the whole
movie
because this is the first movie and i'm
i it could be something else but
and
it was just no buffoonery yeah
culture we we weren't the doorman
you know it's just
i just felt a huge sense of pride
throughout the whole movie and i'm like
wow my kids get to grow up here now this
right here and i'm like wow i get to
experience this with them i don't know
what this means later for them but i
know what it means for me now no doubt
and um definitely want to include i want
to disclose addict on this but just your
feeling on the whole representation
thing with gaming
[Music]
it doesn't matter what i say if i say
something people tell me i'm white i
need to shut up no i say something
that's why it's not not here not here
you're not there
you're my brother
together
no just a gentleman whatever you feel
it's your feeling it's how you feel
brother don't worry it's just something
that it's gonna take time you know you
it's gotta be one of those scenarios
where
i don't think a lot of people are
against it a lot of people are against
like if it's forced right like turning
their favorite characters they they grew
up with turning them to a different
energy like i think it's more of that
than anything else
because like a lot of you know
especially when it comes like women in
games like i've never played a strong
woman woman character in a game like
laura craw cat
and felt you know what i i shouldn't
have played that like i've never i've
usually don't care what that person is
like they could be i mean i played games
that are animals like
i think it's it's just about you know
the more you see
good positive influence like uh i can't
remember one the one from forspoken
what's her name oh yeah damn i know
those guys are making it but i know the
cat yes uh character called female
effort but i do think
i do think because you know and
compulsions game addict or project i
believe project midnight is going to be
also midnight yeah yeah
well i i do think that
there needs to be a company
that will
help other companies with different hair
styles different you know tones because
i feel like
because let's be right here you know
there's a lot of companies that's not in
america there's a lot of companies that
you know especially a lot of eastern
they probably don't even see black
people there so like like i think there
needs to be like an outsourced studio
that someone could go to that does
nothing but customize
does like customization for
for everyone not just you know because
let me
like be real with you like i've never
cared about stuff like that
but it's never i've never felt like i
couldn't make a character that didn't
look like me you know what i'm saying
you see attica always make him i can't
make me
no but it's a good discussion right
because like like mama micah said you
know one of the frustrations you know
especially was was always hair right it
was just like the hair wasn't right
i'll go with the bowl option yeah and
then like you know i don't want to call
certain games out but you know it's
certain games and let's be real you know
as a person of color you go to the
character creator and you're like
just just a different shade on the same
you know and i'm just like like my hair
in square enix games
what's funny is like this japanese cut
[Laughter]
uncle spent like like 45 minutes yes
character
he's like why did you get through
somebody's like i use a preset i don't
care like he's like and i was like i was
like cog you're literally under a mass
they can't see none of that
bro
it's so ridiculous because even people
give me credit for my mass effect
trilogy
representation like i spent so much time
in there because i was like okay they
got this option i could do this i could
do that to get the total right shape not
to mention if they if they start letting
him like a just like like the the how
like fat and stuff is uh oh yeah yeah i
gotta have a muscular show you know we
gotta be outside well it's not even just
that like you can make customize the
you can customize the nose like your
cheekbones yeah you give all those
things the cog
he's probably just going to play that
that's as far as he's getting listen man
i love it man but yeah it's real i'm
glad we had discussed the last thing i
want to give you credit for baba biker
was um when we talk about you know
protagonists of color
we you shared one that really hit home
was was lee from um the the walking dead
and i thought that was awesome you know
the way you described them and for the
people who haven't heard you talk to
colin about it like why does lee from
the walking dead the telltale series why
does he mean so much to you
yeah lee was just he was a father figure
to clementine and that is something that
we lack so much in media is strong black
father figures
and so i'm playing this game and you
have this adorable child that you're
trying to keep safe
and you had you step up and just seeing
that the way that he had dealt with like
prejudice um you know when people find
out about his past or essentially you
know find out that situation he was
involved in prior to like the start of
the game and he's trying to deal with
all of that while being the the only
person taking care of this little girl
in this crazy situation
and he was just a fantastic character
he's calm he's level-headed he's he's
smart he wasn't
at any point you know he wasn't over the
top he was just a real person it felt
like and it was part of representation
it's not just about skin color it's also
about you know who you are
for me as a kid i grew up watching like
hey arnold and realizing all these kids
are poor and that's how i grew up and so
it's not just about how people look it's
also seeing your situation you know
seeing single parent households seeing
people that are low income
and that's what i hope we see even more
of in games is not just diversity of how
people look but you know characters that
maybe they're low income they have
single parent families things like that
to just so you can relate more to the
game when you relate to it that's when
you get so invested in characters that's
when you really feel like i'm having an
experience here and not just pressing
buttons for 40 hours absolutely